ciao ma poi la gomma una gomma plastica
perché no ok ma queste cose da masticare
si è rimasta un po attaccata al dito non
ti avvicinare devo ricaricare che vita
lei abbia imparato la lezione che non
mif accia più dischi benvenuti sua vita
stories oggi il nuovo episodio delle pre
war la guerra degli scherzi come gli
altri episodi ci saranno vari scherzi
che andremo a provare e voi alla fine
del video dovrete votare il vostro a
scherzo preferito e nei commenti
lasciate un bel mi piace se questo video
raggiunge i 20 mila mi piace esisterà un
altro episodio della guerra degli
scherzi mettetevi comodi prendete i pop
corn e e iniziamo ciao ragazzi ho visto
uno scherzo che secondo me è perfetto
per anita ecco qua ho già tutto
andiamo andiamo e tu che cosa stai
facendo quello in mano mi sta
proteggendo ma guarda che io non ho
fatto niente questa volta
ma è una cosa nostra non di nuovo scusa
però più attenta la passava in un'altra
stanza e ha fretta
ciao berlino era solo uno strozzino e
acqua non ti preoccupare che ce lo tocca
a me fare un bello scherzetto vitale e
ha in mente un bellissimo scherzetto
siccome vitale mi ruba sempre da
mangiare lì taglierò qua sotto
lascerò questo pacco di patatine
poggiato qua sulla mia scrivania che
sicuramente cascherà nella trappola
perché ogni volta che vede il cibo
vitale va lo prende e l'oman e spero che
funzionerà liga tra lusitano andiamo ora
qua la parte di sotto e vediamo se
poliziotto tagliando la base con il
taglierino
mi raccomando voi non fate la casa
perché può essere pericoloso
lasciate che li facciamo noi che siamo
pazzi e un po scemi e coop
la scherzetto è pronto ora devo solo
posizionarlo in un font a un po in alto
così sono sicuro che gli cadono addosso
mi raccomando tu non dire niente e
vitale merlino ho visto tutto mi
raccomando in una vita non dire niente a
vitale me lo prometti che non dissi
niente a vitale e bravo merlino promesso
[Musica]
posizionato ora mi basta chiamare vitale
fare finta di niente e sperare che lui
non ti subito il cibo
berlino 6 pronto ora chiamiamo vitale ok
vitale
c'è qualcosa da mangiare qua sembra il
genio vitale ed esprimi tre desideri ma
come cd vestito st pasche presente
volevo fare il giro d'italia
il genio è impossibile perché anche sei
troppo posto che potrebbe spingere
colombo chiederti se senti qualche odore
strano qua potrei di cibo i devi trovare
qualcosa da mangiare nascosto ma secondo
me tu mi stai facendo dello scherzetto
sul sito mi ha nascosto qualcosa faber
quindi per questa volta non aprirò un
niente
mi limiterò a rubare solo questo ciao
non parlo ed invece ciao ragazzi ciao
ragazzi scherzetto super super malefico
per vitale ho preparato un secchio di
pop corn e starete pensando i pop corn e
non sono uno scherzo cattivo anzi sono
buonissime euro sono buonissimi c'è
marino qua sotto che mi sta guardando
con aria famelica vi faccio subito
vedere come funziona questo trucchetto
devo semplicemente appoggiare i pop corn
al soffitto prenderò una sedia spero di
riuscire fuori tenerli fermi con il
bastone della scopa puoi chiamare vitale
e ti ritieni un momento fermo qua così
lui prenderà il bastone non potrà più
muoversi perché se si muove li cadranno
i poker in the proviamo vediamo se
riusciamo a fissarli al soffitto
speriamo che non succeda qualche
disastro tipo che vi cadono addosso a me
no spero di no se berlino qua sotto
tipico da tempo strano sta pensando ma
chi sta facendo ci sono riusciti a
ragazzi di boncore sono visti sul
soffitto
mi fa molto male l'abruzzo devo subito
chiamare evitare per sostituirmi e poi
vedere che cosa falsa di tale
dove sarò proprio volessimo le braccia
vieni subito un emergenza in emergenza
vice devi tenere questa dirigenti questo
cartone tv l'ho visto bene
si no e adesso come faccio ad una loro
del tour lasci andare col bastone tpl
libor corna in testa quindi devi
rimanere così finché non riparare la
lesione brasati cadranno come quinta a
mano finalmente aspettano due soluzioni
la prima è che posso provare a lasciare
questa a prenderla al volo
la seconda è che mi metto a bocca aperta
così prova un bacio che tutti da letto
proprio che chiarirsi ai corrotti
un'idea di non dover mai state spacciate
bot
accettiamo scommesse secondo voi vitale
quanto resisterà così fermo cosenza dax
ma scusa lirico può più ma io devo
tenere le distanze casomai pop corn e
che hanno sulla mia di destra scrivete
nei commenti secondo dove quanto
resisterà vitale permesso giusto secondo
me 5 mi troverà non tanto per cominciò a
far male al braccio
aiutami tu obiettivo qualche buca una
rissa se non ottiene suzuki non ne frega
niente di aiutarti perché non viene
anche tu prima che tu mi dai una mano ma
questo è uno scherzo solo per te cosa
che il prossimo scherzo che però io per
loro sarà cattivissimo come pensi di
uscire da questa situazione vediamo
poletto piano mancandomi tutti i pop
corn
ma è impossibile di cadranno per qualche
addosso niente è impossibile
mi metterò così via
[Applauso]
[Risate]
la scopa eccovi ragazzi lo scherzo di
anita è stato super cattivo per questo
che le farò io adesso uno scherzo ancora
più cattivo ed ecco qui la maschera per
il viso
le dirò che l'ho comprata apposta per
lei devo mettere qualcosa che
all'interno dove mettere il colorante
altrimenti come fa con la erre alla
faccia di tre ditte hanno scegliamo
insieme
eccoci allora vediamo qui che cosa
abbiamo a disposizione vediamo quanti
colori abbiamo la colla rosa alla colla
blu
vi ricordate quello scherzo che abbiamo
fatto ad anita con la colla che era
fiera di collo in faccia se non ve lo
ricordate ve lo lascio qui nel frattempo
cerchiamo di scegliere altri colori
portate avanti se ci sono o forse
dovremmo scegliere loro questo colore
qui il preferito di anita wow
qui abbiamo anche il di lilith portante
che cosa c è dietro decorazioni
coloranti addietro
credo di scegliere proprio questo penso
che il colore giusto sia proprio questo
secondo voi quale sarà la reazione di
anita questo scherzetto
scrivetelo nei commenti ecco guardate
ragazzi ho messo il colorante
non vedo l'ora che reagisca mi sono
sporcando la vita idea allora mi
inventerò che le ho preso la maschera
per fare una spada in casa proprio qui
annita vieni vieni che una sorpresa per
te essi è una sorpresina per te no
perché sei arrabbiata perché non mi
indigna o che io regalo per te perché
c'è la videocamera lì non so perché sto
facendo vedere che ti sto facendo la
sorpresa la sorpresa è la spa in casa ah
sì così tipo di rilassare e poi fare il
trattamento al viso aspetta un momento
che cos'è questo fa stavo facendo lo
slime l'ho dimenticato lì e divisioni
che c'è l'uomo di ok mi sono seduta e
cosa devo fare adesso si rilassi si
rilassino tutto io arresto al
trattamento specifico facciate della
maschera meravigliosamente fantastica ok
ti prego prego si accomodi si accomodi
silversea stand di mano mete stenta a
astrociti ed assistendo
volevo solo togliere per eco prego si
accomodi si stende chiuda gli occhi come
si chiama questa maschera per il viso e
questa si chiama la maschera the green
nel senso che
fatale erbe e quindi perde completamente
naturale fatta con 15 erbe della
campagna massa prima della campagna
anche perché è molto naturale sono tema
raccolte che è messa un nuovo doramare
esattamente tigri di noi abbiamo
prezzemolo a loro ok come è bella fresca
lo sente il profumo della natura come un
attimo bello quindi quali sono questi
ingredienti abbiamo le mani sporche e
nel senso abbiamo abbiamo ingredienti
erba fresca appena appena tagliata noi
abbiamo in ac e broccoli sicuri e
zucchina mi sembra che stai descrivendo
gli ingredienti di una mine fioraso
basta rilassi così lo attende almeno per
20 25 minuti il tempo che faccia offerto
lo spinacio più che altro canto non si
muova vero perché se non del si scolla e
perde tutti i benefici della foglia di
limone
sembra un po strana questa mattina va
benissimo se si è già siete già il
profumo del prezzemolo no animale è
treni sul posto la fiat è normale che
avverte c'è qualcosa di strano in questa
maschera state o il pollice verde
non mi do io me la tolgo no no no deve
fare effettuò lo spinacio siberiano
questo tutti gli estratti delle verdure
negli ortaggi e della frutta il
prezzemolo carote però che non c'entra
con la 5 10 minuti 15 ma io con bruno
viola forse fa ancora per gli effetti
[Musica]
cielo grigio loiero non compresso nella
vasca questa pena capitale
ora si beccherà che hai per caso pure
due il pollice verde
finalmente la ride imparerà a prendersi
cura delle piante
da me la fai
lei scappa oltre certo più cattivo di
tutti
giovedì bravissimo qual'è stata secondo
voi lo scherzo più cammino secondo me
tutto questo perché sempre il grigio un
folletto scrivete nei commenti qual è
stato il voto lunghezza preferita adesso
di un mi piace il continuo della
battaglia degli scherzi perché io ho in
mente una vendetta sofferto per noi
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
of cup su quella che preferite